Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche !
Un peu plus haut, légèrement à l'est...
Voilà, comme ça je devrais bien la voir quand la nuit sera tombée.
Pas la voisine hein?!
L'Étoile du Berger qui d'ailleurs n'estpas une étoile,
c'est une planète c'est le
surnom que l'on a donné à la planète Vénus.
Je sais, c'est un peu confus.
Suivez-moi,je vous éclairer avant que la nuit tombe.
Une étoile est un corps en fusion
qui produitde la lumière, comme le Soleil.
Le Soleil est notre étoile.
Une planète est un corps rocheux comme laTerre
ou gazeux comme Saturne qui tourne autour du Soleil.
Vénus, ici, est l'une des huit planètes dusystème solaire.
C'est une planète rocheuse comme Mercure,
la Terre et Mars, ici en rouge.
Jupiter, Saturne, Uranus et Neptune
sont quant à elles des planètes gazeuses.
Et Pluton dans tout ça, hein, Pluton ?
Pluton est un corps rocheux qui se trouve au-delà
de l'orbité de Neptune.
Il y a quelquesannées, Pluton a été déclassée, rétrogradée
au rang de planète naine.
Mercure, Vénus, la Terre, Mars,
Jupiter, Saturne, Uranus et Neptune.
Un petit truc pour ne pas les mélanger et se souvenir
de l'ordre dans lequel les planètes tournent autour du Soleil.
Vous mémorisez une petite phrase,
une phrase de votre invention dont chaque mot
commence par la première lettre de chaque planète.
Par exemple : "Ma Vieille Tortue Micha Joue
Sur Une Nappe". Vous voyez, ça fonctionne !
Alors Vénus estsouvent considérée
comme la petite sœur de la Terre.
C'est vrai que les deux planètes font à peu
près la même taille et qu'elles ont même âge.
Mais la comparaison s'arrête là.
La température àla surface de Vénus dépasse 450 degrés
et son atmosphère est composée d'acide sulfurique.
Ah oui ! Revenons à nos moutons.
Pourquoi Vénus est-elle surnommée "l'Étoile du Berger" ?
Parce qu'elle brilleplus que les autres planètes
et même davantage que les étoiles qui scintillent dans le ciel.
D'unepart, parce qu'elle est proche du Soleil et d'autre part,
parce que son atmosphère extrêmement dense
renvoit 90 % de la lumière visible.
Un peu comme un miroir.
En fait, Vénus est l'astre le plus brillantdu ciel.
Pour vous donner une idée, elle est 15 fois plus lumineuse
que Sirius, l'étoile la plusbrillante de la voûte céleste.
D'où son surnom "d'étoile".
C'est lumineux ton explicationmais le berger,
qu'est ce qu'il vient faire dans cette histoire, le berger ?!
Eh bien en raisonde son fort éclat une grande partie de l'année,
Vénus est la première à apparaître dans le ciel
du crépuscule et la dernière à disparaître au petit matin.
Pendant très longtemps, elle a doncservi de repère
aux hommes et aux femmes qui vivaient à l'extérieur,
les bergers en particulierqui conduisaient leurs troupeaux
et mesuraient le temps en observant la course des étoiles
et desplanètes. D'où son surnom d'Étoile du Berger".
Si je vous en parle aujourd'hui, c'est parce qu'on
a un peu tendance à confondre l'Étoile du Berger
avec celle qui culmine au sommet du sapin deNoël.
Rien à voir, dans la religion chrétienne
l'étoile du sapin de Noël représente celle que
les Rois Mages sont censés avoir suivis
pourse rendre à Bethléem et offrir des présents
à l'enfant Jésus.
D'après les scientifiques, les rédacteurs des Évangiles se seraient
inspirés d'un événement lumineux
qui s'est réellement produit dans le ciel à cette époque:
le passage d'une comète, une supernova autrementdit
l'implosion d'une étoile en fin de vie
ou plus vraisemblablement le rapprochement
de deux planètes, Saturne et Jupiter.
Encoreune histoire de planètes.
En 2021, Vénus va encore nous offrir un spectacle extraordinaire.
Jusqu'à la mi-février, elle brillera en fin denuit
et à partir de la mi-avril, elle sera la
première à apparaître dans le ciel.
Dernière chose, c'est entre janvier et octobre qu'ellebrillera le plus.
Bon, je m'y suis peut-être prisun peu tôt...
J'en profite donc pour vous souhaiter
une très bonne année 2021 avec des étoiles pleinles yeux
et aussi des planètes.
À très bientôt.
Vénus, et l'une... Non, il fallait que je montre.
Vénus ! On y retourne.
Vénus va encore nous offrir
un spectacle ex...tra...or...dinaire... Paf !
Le berger !